I do not believe we will convince Emma
or anyone at the the majority report or
any liberal or leftist of any of our
positions but I don't care
what I think is important is that we
produced a show where Emma said that she
wanted children to be able to watch porn
at the age of 10 years old and so I'm
like I don't I don't need you to argue
that point to me I don't care what I
need to do is when I'm talking to my my
you know my friend from back home in
Chicago who's telling me it never
happened I'm gonna play that clip of me
being like we should not be showing a
book to children that contains blow jobs
and have this person alive say we should
and it's fine and they're okay with it
and I'm like that's all I needed I
needed for you to say it so I can prove
to people you believe these things